what a few virgins that's right it's me
back at it again with another girlfriend
simulator to show you guys how it's done
how you respect women in a way that
everyone okay let's go everybody I mean
okay hey lembeh look bad
yep the darts on the table and aim the
darts board to target
finally I have a whamon I can play darts
with hey hey along out okay I can walk
wherever I want I see some rocks excuse
me
you do that again oh my god oh my god
never again
whoa look at the view we're like super
rich in stuff can you be quiet please
I'm trying to figure out the controls
okay
this is super annoying
you're watching anime what are you
eating loser
hey listen to me I just realized last
video got demonetised so really why no
I'm too tall I'm too tall for this game
alright what if I I lost my hand
everybody my hand is gone forever can't
I can't reach I can't reach them so how
do i make myself sorter I'm too freaking
tall what is safe I can't how do I make
myself short you be quiet for the love
of God oh okay I got it what if I squat
and then I reach that to hide oh my god
I'm a genius
alright then I reset the height now this
is my new high look at my giant I am God
amongst the ramen fare me tiny one oh
you
I might as well pick these up with my
feet ha god dammit short date oh I can't
do it I'm too tall I'm too tall for this
world I'm out I'm out how tall am I
supposed to be please I can't physically
get any lower yes no no never got way to
go touch it
no shut up got it okay
got it now I got a beat her
oh god damn it
I'm John Doe you stopped Daniel oh god
damn it yes no do I have it I think I
have it yes I got it okay all right
[ __ ] mate civilian teacher maja
ah I got zero points it's been 30
minutes getting zero points all right
what are you guys tell me what your god
a rebate you can't even hit anything
you're nothing you weren't but there
[Music]
whatever whatever I bet you can't yeah
hey honestly that's that was pretty good
great I gotta play again I gotta do it
again I gotta do it again I just got to
do it again I just got to do it again
just got to do it again you just got to
do it again feelings you just got to do
it again yeah yeah yeah I don't mind
doing that it what the heck are you T
posing about no I have to be her
three-times I have to beat her three
times I have to oh my god no cool i'm
even polling and there has to be a way
around this for sure
oh I honestly feel nothing but hey I
can't go below the floor I just can't
what if I place my sensors higher up
would that make a difference oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god I got it
back
shut up what it is anyway
are you kidding me
they don't go in I swear to God I swear
to God they don't go they don't go where
I want them to go they don't go where I
want them to go yes that's a real man
does it that's how a real man does it
[Music]
all right I'm bending the rules I don't
care I don't care yes and I won fair and
square
you schmuck two more
[Music]
get one more chance
I'm just that good I'm just
[Music]
I don't care
no why I mean she let us shut your mouth
okay stop crying
there we go oh my god is that a gun it's
not a gun I get to yes why am I so tiny
now okay all right I'm told what I'm oh
that's
sorry what we're playing a beer game
together beater two times okay you're
going down
[Music]
what's next
are you kidding kidding me
are you kidding me are you kidding me I
did not lose I did not even get hit
alright she's dead now
dead we're all yeah joy yourself
oh that's right that's right you ever
face me again
- skater sugar what was your answer hey
doll ah there you go
[Music]
there you go are we done here
yay Johnny chimpo Chu aye laughs okay
good okay Wendy a blue yonder bah please
stay away from me and this video being
demonetised lalala no sugar Joe Chinese
yeah
John Caleb ah this is just getting weird
what Jen that should help boo boo shop
dear now should help oh please have a
seat have a seat
I'm Chris Hansen yeah and I want to ask
you some questions please have a seat
alright last one then we beat this game
yes help mine find the ready oh my god
are you kidding me are you kidding me
how
you know a junkie Jimmy in the house I
don't know and I don't care what if she
can are you finding it maybe try over
there that clockwork or it oh I can
whoa all right I'll find it make sure
without Julie I find it for my coin
like what see you love me above all
don't jump pop aha
I will find it I will find it for my
queen where is it
I hope I'm not making too much of a mess
I packed I can't
aah it's right there I found it
grab it please please please please
please
Josh Josh I finish the game again give
me your hair No
Jen's Allah are you just gonna go you
[Music]
no hug for me no hug for me I'll never
see right over the hole all right now
that was together beer and oh my god
was it fan taxi leave a like if you
enjoyed by the merch because I will get
demonetized don't spill G fuel on it
because it will get it's designed by me
it's very nice merch it's selling like a
Walmart everybody and I'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
hey won't you have a seat right over
there